probablemente tú has oído el término de
la venta corta de una acción y de hecho
en este vídeo eso es lo que vamos a ver
que dice le baje un poco perdón a la
pantalla ya lo tenemos aquí la venta
corta de una acción en general lo que
significa es apostar a hacer una apuesta
de que el precio de una acción va a
bajar y bueno antes de ver si es
positivo en tu economía o negativo o
inclusive ambas cosas antes de hacer un
análisis completo lo primero que quiero
que te quedes es con esa idea la idea de
que una venta corta de una acción es una
apuesta a que esa acción baje de precio
así que vamos a verlo mejor con un
ejemplo supongamos que nosotros somos la
compañía ibm y bueno también vamos a
suponer que sus acciones cerraron en la
última transacción a un precio de 100
pesos por acción y bueno recuerden que
estamos hablando de suposiciones
realmente no sé en cuanto estén las
acciones de ibm pero ya que estamos
suponiendo también imagínense que yo ya
hice un análisis muy cauteloso de que
las acciones de ibm van a bajar y usted
segurísimo que las acciones de ibm
la bajada iban a bajar hasta 50 pesos no
sé supongamos que le va a ir mal en el
siguiente cuarto de año o en su dado
caso las otras empresas que compiten con
ella van a cerrar mejor el año y por lo
tanto yo estoy convencido después de un
análisis detallado que hice de que las
acciones de ibm van a bajar de 100 pesos
a 50 pesos aunque aquí hay que tener
cuidado porque yo estoy seguro de que
las acciones de la empresa ibm van a
bajar pero no por eso forzosamente van a
bajar entonces como yo estoy
convencidísimo de que van a bajar
entonces voy a ir corriendo con mi
corredor de bolsa o mi agente de bolsa y
entonces le voy a decir lo siguiente
miren aquí estoy yo y tengo un sombrero
alto y no pueden negar que me veo
bastante bien con el sombrero alto pero
bueno regresemos voy con la gente de
bolsa y lo voy a decir quiero pedirte
prestada una acción de ibm sé que en un
principio suena esto un poco raro y tal
vez no entienden muy bien a qué me
refiero y bueno de hecho a mí me costó
un poco de trabajo entenderlo pero
cuando yo digo pedir prestada una acción
realmente lo que me refiero es como
orientar una acción y bueno para
términos más simples voy a pedir
prestado
solamente una acción así que aquí está
mi agente de venta en mi corredor de
venta y tienen los ojos secos pero
realmente no se ve tan mal y estos que
estoy dibujando aquí son todos los demás
clientes de este agente de ventas y
bueno algunos de ellos pueden invertir
en ibm y otros no pero como estamos
hablando de ibm vamos a suponer que
estos que estoy dibujando aquí son las
acciones de ibm entonces como estos son
propietarios de las acciones ellos lo
que hacen es tener una de estas acciones
una o más de estas acciones y bueno
ellos les dan las acciones para que el
corredor de bolsa las manejen ahora bien
en dado caso de que uno de ellos quiera
vender su acción entonces el corredor de
bolsa va a la bolsa de valores vende la
acción y entonces le regresa a su
respectivo pago de 100 pesos por acción
que era lo que habíamos acordado acá
arriba ahora bien si la empresa ibm
emite divisas entonces a cada uno de los
propietarios de una acción le
corresponde no sé supongamos cinco pesos
por lo tanto recibe en cada uno de los
propietarios de las acciones de ibm
cinco pesos por acción pero bueno
nosotros no estamos viendo esto estamos
viendo en el caso
nosotros en contra de lo que todos creen
que van a subir las acciones de ibm
nosotros pensamos que van a bajar las
acciones de ibm por lo tanto lo que va a
suceder es lo siguiente yo voy a ir con
el corredor de bolsa y le voy a decir yo
quiero que me prestes una acción quien
me va a decir cuando tengo todas estas
acciones aquí sin hacer nada te voy a
prestar una acción pero con la condición
de que tú me pagues una renta por esta
acción te voy a prestar la acción pero
tú me vas a dar a cambio una renta
económica por esta acción y es lo mismo
que cuánto rentas un departamento cuando
tu renta su departamento realmente pides
prestado el departamento y tú tienes una
cierta renta el cual es un cierto
interés por el préstamo del departamento
igual con el dinero cuando tú pides
prestado una cantidad de dinero es lo
que haces pagan un cierto interés por
este préstamo del dinero ya eso se le
conoce como renta
y bueno esencialmente tú estás pidiendo
prestada una acción al corredor de bolsa
y puede ser una acción de cualquiera de
estos tipos que tenemos aquí por lo
tanto voy a suponer que es esta ahora
bien qué va a pasar si este tipo
necesita vender su acción al día
siguiente que tú le pides el préstamo al
corredor de whatsapp bueno lo que sucede
es que el corredor de bolsa va a tomar
el perdón que hice no no lo que sucede
es que tú corredor de bolsa va a tomar
prestada una acción del lado de otra
persona y como son iguales las acciones
lo que va a hacer es vender la acción de
la otra persona el propietario original
de esta acción no va a saber ni siquiera
que prestaron su acción y por lo tanto
no hay más bronca con ello ahora bien te
vas a preguntar que esto es un poco
injusto sin embargo no es tan injusto
porque cada una de las personas que
tengo a mi derecha lo que están haciendo
es recibir un cierto beneficio de estas
acciones que el corredor de bolsa está
prestando porque cuando tú pagas este
cierto interés o esta cierta renta de
esta renta un porcentaje se va a ir a
los propietarios de la acción y así
todos contentos el problema no pasa a
mayores y así te pueden prestar la
acción que necesitas para la venta corta
y bueno no solamente pasa esto
mejor vamos a recapitular lo que pasa
para lo siguiente a tú ibas con el
corredor de bolsa le pedías prestada una
acción yo estamos suponiendo que tú le
pides prestar una acción no forzosamente
puede ser así pero en este caso vamos a
ver esta situación entonces se presta
una acción pero uno de los propietarios
de la acción decide vender su acción por
lo tanto el corredor de bolsa deciden
sustituirla con otra acción y por lo
tanto ahora te está prestando la acción
de la otra persona es decir de otro
propietario
ahora bien vamos a suponer que la
empresa ibm decide emitir un dividendo y
por lo tanto a cada uno de los
propietarios de sus acciones les va a
tocar un beneficio de cinco pesos esto
quiere decir que entonces el corredor de
bolsa le tiene que dar a cada uno de los
propietarios cinco pesos pero como a ti
te prestó una acción lo que va a suceder
es lo siguiente te va a pedir a ti los
cinco pesos que le tienen que dar al
propietario de esa acción y es por ello
que va a necesitar una renta de tu
acción con esa renta va a cubrir el
beneficio que va a obtener el
propietario de la acción correspondiente
a que la empresa emita divisas y bueno
ahora sí ya tengo yo mi acción que pedí
prestada al corredor
y entonces ahora qué voy a hacer con
ella bueno lo que voy a hacer es vender
esa acción entonces primero antes que
nada lo que voy a hacer es pedir prestar
la acción y solamente es una acción la
que estoy pidiendo prestada ya que la
tengo lo que voy a hacer es venderla al
mercado y por lo tanto yo voy a obtener
100 pesos de esa acción la voy a vender
a 100 pesos entonces aquí lo voy a
escribir estoy vendiendo la acción y a
cambio obtengo 100 pesos de esta acción
es un momento adecuado para ver con
calma lo que está pasando entonces vamos
a ver qué es lo que pasó con mis activos
y con mis pasivos activos y aquí voy a
escribir mis pasivos pasivos con ve de
vaca muy bien entonces a mi izquierda
están mis activos que por cierto son 100
pesos que obtuve de vender la acción y
en mis pasivos tengo una acción de ibm
lo que debo es una acción de ibm
ahora bien vamos a suponer que mi
predicción es correcta es decir lo que
estoy suponiendo es que después de dos
días de que yo vendí mi acción la acción
de ibm que cotizaba antes en 100 pesos
cierra
ahora en 50 pesos por lo tanto estoy
suponiendo que mi predicción fue
correcta ojo hay que tener cuidado no
forzosamente tiene que ser correcta mi
corazonada puede que no lo sea y ahí
radica el riesgo de este problema pero
bueno en caso de que si lo fuera qué es
lo que va a suceder bueno la idea es que
voy a comprar de vuelta a la acción de
ibm si voy a comprar de vuelta de acción
de ibm pero esta vez no voy a pagar 100
pesos por la acción voy a pagar
solamente 50 pesos porque el precio de
la acción bajó por lo tanto le voy a
poner aquí voy a comprar la acción a 50
pesos entonces yo pago 50 pesos ya
cambio me van a dar otra vez la acción
de ibm que por cierto es mi pasivo es
decir es lo que debía entonces voy a
regresar esta acción al corredor de
bolsa y suena muy bien porque yo obtuve
100 pesos de vender la acción de ibm
pero ahora estoy comprando 50 pesos
entonces perdí 50 pesos la regreso a mi
corredor de bolsa que ésta a su vez aquí
está la acción y esta acción se regresa
de nuevo su propietario cuando ella
quiera utilizar y ese propietario nunca
supo nada de lo que está sucediendo en
cambio para mí estuvo muy bien porque
ahora no tengo
y en pesos tengo de activo 50 pesos
entonces voy a tachar esto de aquí tengo
50 pesos pero que creen ya no tengo
pasivo porque ya para que la deuda de
estación que yo debía entonces ya no
tengo pasivos y obtuve de la nada 50
pesos de ganancia y es que de manera
general en el mercado ocurre lo
siguiente el modelo clásico es tu
comprar a un precio bajo y después
vender a un precio alto y en una venta
corta pasa lo contrario es genial tú vas
a vender a un precio alto primero y
después vas a comprar a un precio bajo
vendes a un precio alto y compras a un
precio bajo pero bueno de cualquier
manera espero que te haya sido útil esto
y bueno este es el escenario correcto el
escenario perfecto es el ideal de
escenario donde tú ganaste algo de
dinero en el siguiente vídeo lo que
vamos a ver es uno de los escenarios
donde corres más riesgo y puedes perder
tu dinero y además quiero crear una
pequeña discusión acerca de si esto es
bueno o malo para el mercado